so this ready has a really weird
conception of english breakfast
so you're coming up and you go diarrhea
in a bowl
i think this is probably the worst
cooking video that i've seen so far
in the last 10 years
hi guys this is gino da campo here and
this is pros
react for lab bible what did we go here
yeah all right so the pizza goes
into the pit water plonker
everybody thinks that making pizza is
extremely easy
and that shows you exactly why
not everybody can make pizza a good
attempt it looked great i thought you
know what what is going to happen
shamble that is an absolutely shamble
okay so i'm watching a clip oh all right
all right so this is a guy who's eating
spaghetti's
yeah he's rolling them up actually is
using a pair of caesar
to cut to the spaghetti because he can't
roll them that is very resourceful i
like that i don't think that's bad
if my mother would have seen that she
would have been really
really really upset okay so we go
the next one where do we go oh dear what
is that
oh mike what so he's got some
spaghetti hopes or or some kind of pasta
in a tin
that is is making into a muffin into a
muffin case
then with cheese on top a ham please
don't taste delicious that looks
disgusting
oh no no mate no no no
it's actually not bad not bad oh my god
that is
rubbish that is the worst thing i've
seen
don't do this recipe guys do not do this
recipe please
creativity right no i don't okay a
lovely pizza
in the oven a bit burned on the side
trying to pick it up
oh i can see where this is going
straight into the fire that's it
it was it's no point mate man give up
give up give up
give up i mean the shovel is the size of
the uh
uh pizza oven uh and
and oh my god i think the wife for the
girlfriend is going to kill him
okay so what do we got here okay so we
got a
guy a chef he's got he's got a gear he's
got a hat he's got everything
so he's opening a pan which i believe is
a
what a [ __ ] i mean sorry i mean
i mean so
okay lo i don't know where to start with
that oh my god
the bloody kitchen is on fire is the guy
alive
is he still alive first of all hot oil
and a lid
i mean seriously the condensation in the
lead is going to go into the oil you
know that is going to catch fire
that is a video that they should ascend
all over the world to tell people what
not to do
when you cook chips honestly someone
who's done that
does not deserve to have a chef jacket
and and a chef hat
get the chips from mcdonald's carry on
doing that the next one we go oh this
lovely lady with a purple top
hello last videos i got a lot of
questions about trying an english
breakfast so today an english breakfast
some british eggs so first get some
british eggs
so this is an american lady all right so
she's cracking egg in a bowl
a little salt in the egg well so far so
good a bit of pepper yeah
sugar sugar add a little whipped cream
and whipped cream whisk it together
whisk it together i mean
this lady has a really in the microwave
so this already has a really weird
conception of english breakfast
so you're coming up and you go diarrhea
in a bowl
my worries is that someone will pick up
this video and think yeah that's what
the british people
eat they put whipped cream and they put
sugar in their eggs and they shovel
everything in the microwave
i think this is probably the worst
cooking video that i've seen so far
in the last 10 years i'm taking back the
spaghetti hoops the guy who did the
spaghetti oops with the whip
with the cheese and a ham that guy in my
opinion
is much better than this lady thank you
so much for
for having me on with you guys it's an
honor thank you guys
mwah ciao another pizza
i'm scared what is this
oh that's a pizza that's another pizza
what do you do with this honestly what
do you do with this pizza
just return it don't even try to cook it
please